(audience applauding)
(upbeat music)
- It's gonna be so cool,
it's gonna be cool.
I know, I know.
(audience applauding)
Wait, wait till you see the movie.
It's a little complicated,
but the chemistry is amazing.
We're gonna talk about it, but I'm,
I'm very excited that you're here.
I'm gonna be so cool.
I might look at him more often.
Just 'cause you-
- I think she's-
- Frighten me in the most amazing way.
- She's gonna cry.
- Yes, yes.
No, I'm gonna keep it together.
- [David] It's okay, you
two just do your thing.
- You are nice, yes.
(everyone laughing)
Not frighted like that, just like,
you know, it's like-
- I'll just be, I'm fine.
- No, no.
(audience laughing)
Well, we met, so, same thing, big fan.
But we met before, so I'm a little,
I'm a little less nervous about it.
I'm a lot nervous about this.
Okay, when did y'all meet?
Did you meet before the film?
- It's a matter of conjecture.
We don't know.
- [Meg] Yeah, we don't
agree on how we met.
- You don't agree?
(audience laughing)
How do you think you met?
- I believe we met in a airport lounge.
- No.
(audience laughing)
- Hard no.
(Kelly laughing)
Hard no, where did you meet?
- In an elevator in a hotel.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, that's so different.
- That's right, no.
- It's so different.
Maybe it was an elevator in an airport.
- Yeah.
(audience laughing)
These characters that we play
in the movie disagree
about everything too.
- [David] It's true.
- Yes.
Like everything in the past
that they don't remember the same way.
- But that's what I find interesting, yes.
Like vantage point and
like point of view of like,
I find that very interesting.
So you're stuck in an
airport this whole time?
- Yes.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- We get rerouted
and we get stuck in a,
one night we're snowed in,
and we haven't seen each other in 20 years
or something like that.
- Which is awkward.
- We have some unresolved things.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
A few.
- Yeah, a few.
- Yeah, I was like, I watch it
and I was like, oh man,
this is so layered.
(audience laughing)
So wait, if you, if you were
trapped though with a co-star,
like that you've worked with before,
who would you, you can't pick each other.
Don't do that.
- No?
- Yeah, you have to pick someone else.
If you were trapped in an
airport, who would you pick?
- That I want to be, or that I?
- That you want to, not,
that you don't want to be.
- What kind of a movie is
it, a horror movie, or?
(Kelly stammering)
- A real life co-star?
- No, this is a friend movie.
It's a friend.
Like what friend would you wanna, yeah.
- Wait, in real life, who
would we wanna be stuck?
- [Kelly] Real life.
- We were just talking
about it, Cloris Leachman.
- [Kelly] Oh, okay, right on.
- Yeah, I worked with her briefly.
She was a blast.
- I like that you went for a
blast and he went to horror.
- [David] Yeah.
- Which explains a lot.
- Tells you something
about my work experience.
(everyone laughing)
- [Kelly] Who would you
want to be stuck with?
- Maybe Pam Adlon, be fun.
- Oh my gosh.
- And I can always count on
her to do most of the talking.
- Okay.
(audience laughing)
Well, you might wanna
be stuck with me then,
cause I'm the talker, so,
I will talk your head off.
So, eight years off, right,
from doing like films and stuff?
- [Meg] Yep.
- Like, so why that?
I appreciate that, 'cause
even in the music world,
it's nice to have a break.
- I didn't try, I just,
I've basically just been
hanging around, I mean.
(audience laughing)
Like talking, talking to my
friends, raising my kids.
Like, redecorating.
- I know, that's the important
thing too, though, yeah.
- And then during Covid,
this script came to me
and I was like, oh, I've
always wanted to write.
I've always wanted to write a screenplay.
So, that's what happened.
It's, you know, it's a movie, basically,
they're locked down in the movie together
and we were locked down at the time.
And I had all this time to write.
- What a perfect movie to
do in the lockdown time.
- [Meg] Exactly.
- Because it's really y'all.
- Yeah, it's just.
- I think you probably thought,
well, you didn't know how long
the lockdown was gonna last,
so, it was a movie that you
could have actually shot
during the pandemic.
- That's what I mean, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- There's just two of us,
that's it, that's all.
- Except for all the people
that were actually in the airport.
- Except for the, yes, the extras.
- But we're the only ones who talked.
- They're not extras.
No, they're, these were,
it was a working airport.
You know, these were actual people.
- [Meg] Like they were real people.
- [Kelly] Are you serious?
- In fact, I recognize some of them.
(audience laughing)
- So, I have to say
you're both in rom-coms
that are so massively popular
that people love and adore, so-
- But I'm not.
- You are.
"Return to Me" is like one of my favorite.
What?
(audience laughing)
So wait, what's your,
what's the best time you
feel to watch a rom-com?
When do you watch, like,
it's like sad music.
When do you listen to?
- When you're sick.
When you're getting over being sick.
- [Kelly] When you're sick, yes.
- That's what people tell me anyway.
(everyone laughing)
- [Kelly] That is true.
- Yeah.
Like, when you're recovering and you feel
like you cracked it and
you're on the upswing.
- You need something nice.
- [Meg] Yeah.
- Yes.
- [Meg] Kind.
- That's when I watch Doris Day.
- Yes, yes, exactly.
- All those old things.
- [David] Really?
- Yeah, you just wanna feel good.
- How about you?
- That's what I do.
I watch, I, well, I watch
a real well-known film
called "Return to Me",
(audience laughing)
and "You've Got Mail".
I was going to say, I watch all those.
When you wanna watch a rom-com,
what do you, what mood are you in?
- I don't, I don't know.
I think, here's my honest answer.
When I find one, when
I'm flipping, flipping.
It's either "Good Fellas"
and people are gonna kill each other
or it's a rom-com.
- I could go with that, too.
I get into "The Equalizer"
whenever I'm like,
not feeling good and I just
wanna kick someone's ass.
(everyone laughing)
- Yeah.
- It's a good movie.
Well, it's not a rom-com, but anyway.
(audience applauding)
Take a look at their new
movie, "What happens Later".
It's in theaters today.
(audience applauding)
So, I found this incredibly interesting,
'cause I didn't find this out
until after I watched the movie,
but you aren't initially
going to be the lead.
- No, no.
- [Kelly] So what happened?
- We tried to get someone else and,
and she didn't wanna be in it.
And so, then we landed on me
and then we landed on David.
- Okay, right on.
- So, yeah.
- Oh my gosh.
First of all, I wanna hold
back conversation on that
off camera, but who says no to Meg Ryan.
Cool, okay.
But I'm kind of glad, I think it ends up
how it's supposed to end up,
because I honestly, after watching it,
I was like, I can't picture
anyone else in that role.
- [Meg] It's kind of the
point of the movie, actually.
- Yeah, you can't picture it, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- I'll say no more.
She's like, I don't wanna spoil it, yeah.
- We shot for 21 days.
We only had a teeny amount of money.
21 nights.
- Yeah.
- Maybe 18 nights, that was the hard part.
- The night part.
- Yeah.
- That was shot in that
minimal amount of, wow.
- Yeah, yeah.
And there's just, well,
like we said before,
just two people in it.
So, I thought it was manageable.
When I got this during the
Covid, I thought, oh, we could,
(audience laughing)
we could do this.
We could figure it out.
There's just two, two, you know.
It's just very distilled experience.
- And it does play out like a play.
Like, I feel like you
could literally watch this
on stage on Broadway.
- Yeah, initially was a play,
but then it, sort of
basically rewritten, but yeah.
And we shot in Arkansas.
We shot in northwest
Arkansas in Bentonville,
which was fantastic.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Really fantastic with us.
- Arkansas's beautiful.
- We loved being there.
And we shot it in a museum
and the real airport.
So we combined it, 'cause it
needed to be a magical world.
- But in the movie, yeah, in the movie,
you just think we're in the airport
and all of a sudden we're
in a beautiful airport
and not so beautiful airport.
- Well, I love that you
said magical though,
cause there is a lot of magical realism.
Like, there's things that
happen that I was kinda like,
when I was watching, I
was like, wait, what?
I was like, 'cause things
are talking directly at you,
even in the trailer,
that's kind of given away.
- The environment is a, but you know,
I always think of it.
I love the idea that
there's a larger plan.
There's a benevolent force out there
and it operates on these two idiots,
(audience laughing)
who can't get it straight.
And it's a forever sort of
like trying to broker their,
like, making some peace
or getting some clarity
or understanding the facts.
Getting some closure, right.
- Yeah, absolutely.
So, I noticed that you
dedicated to Nora Ephron.
So what's your favorite memory of her?
- That's a great question.
She gave great dinner parties,
and they were all,
and actually, I started
to understand that like,
the being on the set with
her was, the idea was
that it should feel like
one of her dinner parties.
Like you wanted to talk to everybody,
didn't want it to end.
There was great conversation
and she had like, just
pure delight in filmmaking.
And she, you know, I understand now,
like you have this quiet little revelation
at like 5:30 in the morning
about how characters talk to
each other and it's just yours.
And then, cut to you're on a set
and 150 people are trying to
like, have opinions about that.
- Yeah.
- Trying to make it alive, you know?
And that's a really delightful,
magical little twist, turn.
And she, embraced that.
She loved that.
- I love that.
And dinner parties, those
are exhausting to throw.
(audience laughing)
Like, I'm always so tired.
I'm always like, I'm
never gonna do this again.
And then I, do it again, but whatever.
- You should tell her about
getting the dedication on,
you'll like this.
- The WG, the WG, the
DGA, the Director's Guild
is very proprietary, rightfully so.
Like the very first thing you
see at the end of a movie is,
is the directed by credit.
And in order to-
- That's the law.
- It's the law.
(audience laughing)
In order to usurp that,
you had, we had to petition
the DGA to like,
these are the reasons why I'd
like to dedicate it to Nora.
And unanimously they voted yes.
- Oh wow.
(audience applauding)
That's very cool.
Well, it's a beautiful thing.
And it was nice after
watching this amazing story
of these two people and then seeing that.
That was really cool.
It was a beautiful thing to do.
So, do people ask you,
just 'cause you're in romantic movies,
do they ask you for real advice?
Sometimes I think people
get lost in the fact
that you're playing a character
and it's not really you,
but do they stop you
often and ask for advice?
- Do they?
- They don't stop me.
- Oh.
(everyone laughing)
- Maybe they should.
All right everybody, we are back
with Meg Ryan and David Duchovny,
(audience applauding)
in their new movie "What Happens Later".
Meg and David play a couple
who just couldn't work things out.
Sometimes things just don't work out
and sometimes, there are
definite deal breakers.
It's time to find out if we'd tolerate
some relationship situations
with a game called,
I'm Sorry, But That's a Deal Breaker.
(upbeat music)
♪ I'm sorry, but that's a deal breaker ♪
(audience applauding)
What would be amazing in life?
It would be amazing in life
if you really were in this situation
and somebody just came in and sang that.
♪ I'm sorry ♪
- Let's have her back here.
- And then you just leave.
You save your time.
Anyway, here's how it works.
I'm gonna hit the button and a relation,
this button, particularly,
and a relationship situation
will pop up on the screen.
Then we'll each have to say
if it's a deal breaker for us-
- Are you sure it's the right button?
- And why.
Yeah, I'm totally sure.
- All right.
- I'm a great host.
Here's the first one.
(upbeat music)
(bell chiming)
Okay, you're on a first date and he takes
a 10 minute call from his mom.
(audience booing)
Then puts you on the phone.
That's different for,
I feel like people in the public eye.
Have you ever been on it with people
and they're like, oh,
can you talk to my mom?
And I'm like, is this happening?
'Cause you're in the public.
Like, you know, they get excited,
'cause you're-
- I think no matter what,
it's a deal breaker.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Hit it.
(audience applauding)
- Okay.
♪ That's a deal breaker ♪
(Kelly laughing)
Jesse, where were you?
- It doesn't work.
(Kelly laughing)
- What about you, is it a deal breaker?
- What was the question?
(audience laughing)
- Maybe you're the guy on the phone.
(everyone laughing)
No, is it, is it, would
it be a deal breaker
if the person left?
- I don't know, a good
friend of mine, Bart Fronik,
wrote a script in which
he had a first date
and the guy stopped at a porta-potty
on the way to the dinner and start,
and kept talking to the girl
while he was inside the porta-potty.
- She was outside?
(audience groaning)
- And I just thought it was
one of the funniest scenes
I'd ever read.
(audience laughing)
- I don't know if that's a deal breaker.
- Hit it!
(upbeat music)
♪ I'm sorry, but that's a deal breaker ♪
(audience applauding)
(David laughing)
- I think that would be a
deal breaker for me too.
That's weird.
I took time to have dinner
and you're going off for 10 minutes, okay.
Okay, here we go, next one.
(upbeat music)
(bell chiming)
Okay, okay.
He shouts out, that's,
(Kelly laughing)
(audience laughing)
he shouts out, that's what she said
when the minister at your sister's wedding
claims the ring doesn't fit.
It's too big.
(audience laughing)
- Oh my God.
- That's when you know
you made the right choice.
(audience laughing)
- That is not a deal breaker.
- I'm gonna be honest with you, no.
I think I'm attracted to
a different type of person
that I actually would be like, all right,
it's a throwback, but I'll take it.
(audience laughing)
It's a throwback classic.
(everyone talking simultaneously)
I'd be like, yeah, I'm
going home with that one.
(everyone laughing)
I think I'd have to make a joke.
Would you, would that be a deal breaker?
- What a joke at a wedding?
- No, it's not a deal breaker.
- Or would you ever say that at a wedding?
- I wouldn't say that.
- No.
(audience laughing)
But it is an opportunity.
- It's an opportunity that you would miss.
- I've got a captive audience.
(everyone laughing)
I can't resist trying
to be funny, sometimes.
- [Kelly] I'm just saying.
- It could happen.
- It could happen, it could happen.
Here we go.
(upbeat music)
(bell chiming)
Okay, on the second date,
she invites you up or he
invites you up to her apartment
in which she has, oh,
seven cats, 12 rabbits and a
rare Spix's macaw named David.
(audience laughing)
(Kelly laughing)
By the way, I think you have
shown up to my mother's house.
So, she like has a lot of animals.
So I was like, I read that
and I was like, did we,
did they visit my mom's?
She has a lot of animals.
A macaw named David.
She'd be a fan.
- I'd be like, Mrs. Clarkson, all right.
(everyone laughing)
- Interesting night.
And so, what about you?
Would it be a deal breaker?
- That's not a deal breaker.
- [David] You love animals.
- I love animals.
- And the macaw name, I can see,
I can see how it had a certain appeal.
- [Kelly] I love animals.
- David is a funny name
for an animal, though.
- But think about this.
So it comes back to
the apartment scenario.
Like, if you're in a house
and those are somewhere else,
I think I'm fine with it,
but an apartment, I grew
up in an apartment, no.
- [Meg] Oh, it's an apartment, okay.
- Yeah, that's an apartment,
that's real close.
- I didn't think about it.
- [Kelly] That's close quarter.
- 12 rabbit.
- [Kelly] Cats and rabbits.
- Close to 24, 36.
- Rabbit turds get everywhere.
- Yeah, rabbits are rough.
- [Kelly] Super toxic.
- And they roll.
- We keep ours outside.
- [Meg] Deal breaker.
That's a deal breaker.
Okay, here we go.
(upbeat music)
(bell chiming)
Okay, he claims that under
is the proper way to,
(Kelly laughing)
are y'all making fun of me?
This is, this is my crew making fun of me
because I like it to
roll over the top, okay.
He claims that under is the proper way
to roll the toilet paper
and it's a deal breaker for
him if you think otherwise.
Here's the thing, it's
not a deal breaker for me.
I prefer the toilet paper
to roll over the top,
but I also prefer to have my own bathroom.
So, I don't really care,
what his bathroom looks like.
Are you an under or over?
- I don't like that he setting
up a deal breaker right away.
- Yeah, that's a weird thing.
- That's in a way, a deal breaker.
- That's a character flaw, yeah.
- I'm uncomfortable.
(everyone laughing)
- Do you, are you a person, I'm an over,
are you a person that
likes it under or over?
- [Meg] I don't know that about myself.
(audience laughing)
- You don't have a preference?
- No.
- I guess I'm over.
I'm thinking about it.
- I'm over.
- Okay.
(audience laughing)
- Yeah, I'm over.
I prefer over.
(audience laughing)
- Oh my God, I love you so much, okay.
Here we go, one more.
(upbeat music)
(bell chiming)
Okay, he reveals to you
just before your wedding
that he was, oh,
that he was taken into an
alien spaceship when he was 23
and they'll be back for
him in about four years.
(audience laughing)
- Is it your wedding to him?
- I think, well he's, he's
gonna leave maybe in four years,
which-
- Oh.
- That sounds good.
- I know.
(audience laughing)
I've never tried long
distance relationships, but
(audience laughing)
seems nice.
- It's a long commute.
- Seems you could get your you time.
- Easy four years.
- Yeah.
Yeah, you're only
committing for four years.
- [Meg] Exactly.
- Sign me up!
(everyone laughing)
(audience applauding)
Cause the other one sounds like jail, so.
I don't know, I don't
know what I'd say, anyway.
Do you know what you'd,
would you just go for it?
I'd go for it.
- Well-
- I like the four year part.
- Yeah, I'm into it.
- I would feel-
- I feel like I would love to
be in a therapy session with you just to,
cause every question you go big.
You go the whole scope of it, man.
You're a big thinker.
I am very literal,
in a complimentary way.
No, I mean, I mean it as a compliment.
(audience laughing)
I, no, I mean like you
like think of so much
in one question.
I'm like, I'm just like, I don't know.
Would you go to space or not?
I'm so, like, you're Yale
and I'm high school graduate.
(everyone laughing)
That's the difference.
- I would love to be in
therapy with you too.
(everyone laughing)
- You probably would.
You wouldn't have to talk.
(everyone laughing)
All right, those are our deal breakers.
- Therapist would be like
what's the guy's name again?
- You came with-
- Oh, David, hey, okay.
(everyone laughing)
- Oh, he's here.
Okay, everybody go see
"What Happens Later".
It's incredible and
it's thought provoking,
which is the best kind of movie.
(audience applauding)
It will leave you asking
so many questions.
We'll be right back.